in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Nathan
and Emil are with us hey guys how are ya
good well great
welcome welcome good to have you and
what do you say Emily I said it wrong
I'm social funny I can't read that's
awful
so where you guys from we have traveled
over 6,000 miles in a van from Knoxville
Tennessee we're doing to drive 200 we
found you
so you've been all over the country and
then stopping back on their way home yes
okay very cool very cool
nice big big trip how long you been gone
is it been over a week
Wow and and 6,000 miles and how many
kids in the van four yeah that's like
24,000 mile one in the diaper so you got
that right yeah you have used an
exponential factor with that travel so
you're here to do your debt-free scream
yes how much have you paid off a hundred
and ten thousand that's amazing it took
us about ten years of working it but the
last three is when we said enough let's
get over with all right I'm will counter
this three okay because that's when you
got serious there and your range of
income over the last three years when
the last three years it went from the
50s and made 76 last year and we'll make
more this year so we're on our way up
finally cool what do you guys do for a
living I Drive for UPS but I also have a
landscape business that I started years
ago when I was working towards full-time
with the company and it was about two
years ago I went full-time and I'm still
maintaining that I've got boys old
enough to weed eat and carry and push
wheelbarrows so maintaining some weekend
work for now child labor absolutely I
love it Emily what do you do I stay at
home with the kids we homeschool so
horrific very cool so I want to hear
different parts of this story but let's
start with 36 months ago when you got
serious what happened that caused the
switch to flip we've always wanted to be
debt-free and we we were debt-free while
ago and then purchase land so really
this has just been our mortgage and we
just said enough we want to be debt-free
that's our big goal and so we're going
to really buckle down and
and do it yeah we've been cash flowing
things I need a piece of equipment so we
cashflow that that cut into some savings
we're saving for a new car we're saving
but we would dip into those savings as
things life happened to us and finally
we realized over all of our named
savings accounts and funds and things we
got some cash built up here if we do it
and focus with the energy that we began
with ten years ago this is our year I
said 2015's are your kids we're getting
debt-free this year instead of yeah
we're working towards it we're doing it
this year and wouldn't you know when you
stay to go say it out loud and revisit
it often it happens there it is yeah
there it is that's it and so you this is
your house and your land is all paper
you wrote out of any kind it's correct
so what's your property in your house
worth Oh 180s to our neighbor behind us
Sonia's his property for about two
hundred seventy five thousand all right
you know we'll see what he gets and I'll
tell you what my it's worth I won't
count that yeah that's good very cool
and you guys are how old I just turned
40 how about 38 and you have a paid-for
house yeah weird people man that's
amazing well congratulations I'm so
proud of you guys
you're heroes I mean you've completely
changed your family tree we have I just
want to say when our neighbors decided
that they wanted that they were gonna
move in sell their property with that
other property
connects to ours we have 10 acres they
have 10 acres that would be perfect and
so we kind of just kicked kicked around
and this was two weeks after we paid off
our mortgage loan and so we talked to
the kids and they said well what do you
think you know and as we were kicking
around they said well that means we'd
have to go back in debt let's not do
that so I was just a light bulb moment
that they're already saying no we're not
gonna go back in debt we're not going to
do that and that's when you know you
really changed your family drew yeah
they've been a big part of this and
they've sacrificed along with us and so
looking special that's big that's big
right there that's when it matters yeah
that all you just remember that little
face when they said that you got never
borrow money again I feel like they
don't that'll wrap that up for sure
you're not always a hard work to get out
of dad and clean up this mess and you
guys have sacrificed but when you're
looking in that little face you're
thinking legacy yeah you know you're
thinking this is this family tree has
permanently changed you guys are
impressive so
when people hear that in 36 months you
paid off a hundred and ten thousand
dollars making fifty to seventy six
thousand and they say how do you do that
what are you telling the secret to
getting out of debt is it's you've got
to be you've got to be happy you gotta
have energy and drive you got to have
that goal you're driving towards but
then you guys stay focused
believe me Dave those days where I was
sick of it I'm time we have over a
million miles of vehicles in our
driveway because I've got two beaters
and two pretty good vehicles people say
won't you buy a new truck won't you buy
a new vehicle cuz we've got a goal and
we're focused so when we're staying
determined but those moments when you
Wayne I would turn on the Dave Ramsey
show and here's somebody going and I
would get chills and get driven and not
be ready to take on the world again so
you need to recharge you need to build
in little rewards so you're not just
running yourself dry and then it's all
about staying focused it's baby steps to
the end man wee baby steps are way to
this big moment love it I would say I
when I would have kind of those weak
moments I really want to get this or I'd
like to do that I remember growing up my
dad would always say never trade what
you want most for what you want now at
the moment and then I would think it
would help me to think okay do I want
this hamburger more than I want to be
debt-free or do I want this dress more
than I want to be debt-free do I want to
go to a movie more than I want to be
debt-free and always the answer was no
and so then it was easy to stay on track
so that's very good though your dad's
got a great line there now why is it so
important to be debt-free to you guys
because what does it give you freedom if
my husband loses his job nobody can come
take our house
I don't worry about paying the next bill
or I don't worry about paying our
mortgage we have we have our emergency
fund and when somebody ribbons I don't
know my family's safe security you know
it's powerful it's liberating I feel so
free so in control of my life it's
wonderful and what what really you
haven't got yet that you're gonna get in
the next few months is that now you've
got control of your largest wealth
building tool you're gonna be wealthy
not just secure you'll be wealthy
I mean that that's you're gonna be
wealthy you know I mean really the money
you used to pay out on that that alone
will make you wealthy mathematically I
mean this is not me like you know
there's no smoke blowing this is just
math you're gonna be wealthy you know so
you're more than just secure Emily
you did it this is awesome this is very
cool you live like no one else now
you're gonna be able to live and give
like no one else and protect your family
that's very cool
that is so exciting you guys are
impressive very very fun I'm proud of
you know your kids names and ages
Porter is 11 almost 12 Ezra is 9 Korra
is 7 and Elias five months oh five month
old though you said you had diapers in
there so we coming into the picture
Dorothy thinks just stay out oh oh we
don't want to hurt her ears oh okay
all right you don't want her to you
scare the baby to death all right all
right so Porter Ezra Cora Ellie Nathan
and Emily from Knoxville Tennessee a
hundred and ten thousand dollars paid
off 40 years old everything's paid off
no house payment you're looking at
listening to a weird family counted down
let's hear a debt-free scream ready
Oh
good scream ladies and gentlemen well
done well that's it right there that's
the sound of a family trees changing you
always wanted to know what it sounded
like
that's the sound of it it's when the
mama and the daddy make different
decisions about their life and the
future life of their kids and based on
that they decide to get control of their
money it's that simple it is that simple
and you know they didn't sit around got
you know the economy's bad you know you
know middle-class wages haven't gone up
you know the minimum wage is low they
say that did they they increase their
income $25,000 about 50% in their case
over the last three years and working
their butts off is what that means
because they had a goal and they were
focused you everybody said and they're
throwing gas on the fire man it's like
getting out you know what you heard
their emotion in her voice don't worry
about somebody taking their stuff they
own it they own it changes everything
this is the Dave Ramsey show hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show and so
you have to break the cycle you have to
flip this thing on its head
and make it behave you've got to get so
fired up and wired up that your broke
friends think you've lost your mind
you